[Music]
great well let's turn to all you
conscious agents in the audience for
your questions
could I have yes the person their
microphone that and also I'll take well
yes maybe I'll send the microphone to
the people on the front too yes thank
you and then if I take if I take all
three questions we'll do a combined
response yes and thank you so much um my
questions many directed to you Donald
and I just I wanted to know
perhaps I've misunderstood you but I
want to know a little bit more about
what you are fascinating you made when
you said that you've did this research
on these creatures and you said that the
ones that had a worse sense of reality
weren't necessarily or just that they
were more that they having a wesen
throughout he didn't make you less able
to reproduce that there wasn't a
correlation there right that someone's
survival as a species isn't related to
how much they see that it's real and I
want to tell you figured that out if we
don't know what it's real you know like
how could quickly and and secondly I
wanted to know I just feel that with
this road and this grandeur tooth
metaphor which I understand I mean how
do you feel about being in a world where
as time moves on and as we evolve we are
less and less able to move off that road
and drive off a cliff or turn around and
like you know to go off grid like we're
less and less able to go off grid
potentially if we're increasingly
restricted to reality where we're just
doing adaptive actions so yeah that's
all thank you okay great lovely well
maybe you should deal with that as it
had two questions within it and then all
the other people otherwise yeah so you
want to start with you know exactly how
do we know that if we don't have that's
a great question real it turned that
might seem like magic but it turns out
all I need to assume about reality in
this proof it's a theorem what I'm
telling you is a theorem of evolution by
natural selection that organisms that
see reality as it is are never more fit
than organisms have seen none of reality
and are just tuned to Fitness payoffs
and it turns out that's true regardless
of what reality might be I didn't need
to assume anything about reality except
that it has a set of states
at all I need and so it and the key idea
is a little technical but in
evolutionary theory there are things
called Fitness payoff functions they're
functions that depend on the state of
the world and they tell you how many
fitness points you'll get for various
actions and all you have to do is
analyze those Fitness payoff functions
you can ask how many of those Fitness
payoff functions would actually preserve
some structure in the world like a total
order or topology or whatever it might
be and you can prove using combinatorics
simple mathematics you can prove the
probability of that a payoff function
will preserve any structure in the world
is zero and that therefore since natural
selection Tunes us to the payoff
functions and the payoff functions
themselves do not preserve structures in
the world are our census could not
possibly be tuned to structures in the
world it's actually a straightforward
proof great thank you
do you want to do the increasingly
adaptive right right so I don't see this
as constraining us at all I think this
is liberating I mean when I went to we
thought that we thought this was the
final reality what this says is there's
another aspect to reality that we've
never been open to before the reason I
got into this was because there's a
problem in science called the hard
problem of consciousness that we can't
crack we're trying to figure out how
neural activity causes your experience
of the taste of chocolate or the smell
of garlic how does that happen we have
these correlation between brain activity
and conscious experiences there is no
scientific theory that can explain it
the reason I got into this was ugly was
beginning of thing we're doing the
problem the wrong way we're assuming
neurons create consciousness why might
that be wrong and that's why I looked at
evolution and realized oh neurons exist
only when I perceive them they couldn't
possibly boot up my consciousness so now
we have to rethink this heart problem of
consciousness which is one of the
biggest open problems in science today
you know completely new framework that's
one deal the conscious agents done great
thank you okay so we have well hoards of
questions on the front I'm just gonna
take this person here and go check
hi this is a question for Donald I was
just trying to understand something and
yeah trying to add something and you
were saying I think that that there's
game theory strategy doesn't need space
and time and I think I wrote down some
phrase you said which was something
about actions and consequences and I was
sort of thinking well isn't a game
theory strategy and actions and
consequences meaning that you have to
have a cause and effect and time and
space to have a game theory strategy and
actions and consequences if you strip
out space and time you can't have a game
theory strategy right so that's a great
question so the first thing is that in
in evolution evolutionary game theory we
don't even talk about genes and things
like that DNA it's only about strategies
that that are competing with each other
for for resources and so forth and all
you need in in the mathematics and this
is by the way this is the mathematician
when we talk about evolution by natural
selection this is the mathematical
content of it we've discovered this in
the last 40 years that's what we mean by
evolution by natural selection so so it
it it captures everything that we need
and it doesn't the notion of causality
that's in there does not require even
space and time it's all you need are
strategies that lead to certain outcomes
and the causality that you is not even
in space and time so it's it's a very
very powerful tool it's and but the
power of it by the way I should mention
something you asked me about which was
what about mathematics I said that
evolution means we don't see the truth
about the real world doing physical
objects what about math haven't I shot
myself in the foot if math isn't true
and it turns out math doesn't fall under
my theorem and the reason for that is
this you need to be able to reason about
Fitness payoffs a creature that doesn't
understand that two bites of an apple
give you more fitness payoffs than one
bite of an apple is it regardless what
an whether an apple is true or not is
just a fitness pal
if you don't understand that you can get
more payoffs by doing certain things
then you will not be fit
so there are selection pressures to
actually have some minimal competence in
mathematics and logic not there are not
selection pressures to be geniuses but
just enough to beat the competition by
the way that's the evolution does not
try to make geniuses all you have to do
is just beat the competition by a little
bit and you're fine great thank you
someone got a question for the panel as
a whole though it's lovely to hear from
Donald - have you got one for everyone
well I'll turn to you at the end I'll
remember or remind me collectively yes
the person there please so when you guys
are speaking about you know reality not
being something we can understand
obviously it really makes you think of
Convery strongly and I want to know if
that that does imply you know that the
way to seek knowledge is to figure out
perhaps how what's the process by which
those icons are created or the process
by which creates the way we view a
reality and if your ideas are so similar
to cut do you have I think his biggest
criticism was you're making the
assumption himself does your do your
ideas rely on that and you know in fact
it for the lady all the way to the right
you seem to be saying you know we exist
in the world
we need the stree act you know does that
kind of help you to think you know we we
exist within the world and and maybe if
you make the assumption that there's an
outside world separate to us that
assumption is too much and that's where
the the hubris comes in on their end
what you mentioned here about the self
reflexive
problem as well do you want to go first
marina sure sure ah the position I'm
taking is auntie Conti on Kant was the
anti-realist par excellence in
conceiving of the world as the thing in
itself existing out there and then the
phenomenal world is the world that we
construct to our concepts etc for Kant
we are all constructed the world the
same way through the same categories
rational categories I think for Hillary
there will be different ways of
constructing the world so that's that's
a departure from camp but the basis is
income for me on the other hand there is
another tradition in philosophy where it
says that we do engage directly with the
world we get things wrong and we make
lots of mistakes but also we try to get
things right so there is no ultimate
truth that we create we discover but we
just move towards the truth and that
that's a completely different tradition
in philosophy are not the country yes
yeah no quite which elements to respond
to I mean I think that Kant started from
a position of saying we we need to
account for how it is that we know
things and build a structure of how
there is knowledge even though he has a
he says we can't describe the noumenon
string she never I started in a very
reverse situation of thinking isn't the
contemporary situation that we know that
we and says no nothing and and how how
is it that despite the fact that we know
nothing we are able to intervene and
when I say no nothing that we are unable
to give a definitive account of anything
in the 20th century one of the things
we've uncovered is the extent to which
with the frameworks that we thought
delivered us with definitive outcomes
have gradually been undermined by a
recognition of the perspective character
they're limited to language culture
history society and so forth and so we
we don't have that knowledge framework
and yet were able to intervene so in
since I'm coming from the opposite issue
of thinking we haven't got that
knowledge but how is it that we are able
to do all of the things that we can do
and to build a framework
enables an account of how that's the
case and it goes I have ended up with
something that does have some elements
of similarity with can but as Murray was
saying I would choose different ways of
describing the detail of how we create
our in my firm closures and how they we
give them meaning and how it is possible
that we're able to do things even though
it's not backed by some ultimate stuff
great thank you I've just seen there's a
piece of blue paper that's going to put
that which I know isn't real but it
means I only have two minutes so I'm
going to really briefly honor my promise
to the matter if you can have a really
quick question which will answer very
briefly - it seems like your theory is
similar in some ways to pragmatism that
there the reality as we perceive it is
what is useful and I wonder and also in
an in some ways to Buddhism in the sense
that we what we perceive is essentially
a losery and I just wondered if you'd
found after having come to your theory
from your evolutionary game theory
models if the narrative was reminiscent
of anything if there was any other
theories or perhaps people that had
approached the same conclusions but from
different ways of thinking about the
world that you came across yes
so it I differ from pragmatism in the
sense that I also think there is a
deeper form of reality so the pragmatic
thing comes from evolution within our
interface and the interface is pragmatic
it but there's a deeper reality so in
terms of like Kant's and so forth Kant's
says the phenomena which is what I would
call the interface is our empirical
reality but he says there's an umma know
that we can't see my difference with
Conte is that concept we cannot do
anything about the new no we can't give
a theories of it and that's really bad
for job security and science and so I
can't go there so I it's my job as a
scientist to try to propose a theory of
objective reality caught might be right
but I can't
[Laughter]
[Applause]
in the debates talks and inter points
subscribe to daily to the Institute's
arts an ideas her III TV
you